vous massez plus la pudeur et dans danse
avec les stars que dans des films pour
adultes
mais en fait vous comparez quelque chose
que je peux comprendre vous interpelle
comme ex patiente quelqu'un dit je me
suis mis à nu non mais je vous comprends
en fait il faut juste remettre autres
parfois on dit elle renie pas ce qu'elle
veut pas en parents non c'est totalement
faux en réalité je ne changerai pas une
virgule à ma vie parce que je ne serais
pas devant vous apprendrez gardé de même
non plus exactement au point de changer
le nom m'a toujours semblé absurde parce
qu'il faut assumer ce qu'on fait mais
simplement quand on fait les choses est
de 19 ans on le fait avant les faits
avec un tel enthousiasme un tel
enthousiasme une telle légèreté et
libertés moi je voulais juste quelque
chose c'est que je veux je voulais être
libre
je voulais m'émanciper de mon éducation
je voulais dire merde à tout le monde
voulait venir à paris ve que je prouve
je trouve ainsi une marseille je voulais
dire tout ce qu'on m'a appris je le mets
de côté je veux devenir femme et mon
corps et mon esprit m'appartiennent
c'est très très important pour moi vous
comprenez qu'à 38 ans je n'ai pas du
tout les mêmes attentes
j'ai une vie pour l'instant
extraordinaire la plus belle chose que
j'ai fait dans ma liste et ma fille et
je veux la protéger de tout de tout
l'est nous les death toutes les
décisions que j'ai prises moi même et
qui ont parfois atteint ton parfois
touchants parfois blessés elle c'est ma
princesse c'est mon bonheur c'est mon
secret trop lui et si vous voulez quand
j'en parle même si je ne dis jamais son
nom et si je ne montre jamais son visage
monsieur votre souhait autres je ne veux
en aucun cas que mes décisions pèsent
sur sa vie que ce soit à l'école le
costa l'imam on savait les parents
d'élèves
donc c'est ma plus grande pudeur
effectivement c'est ma fille ce n'est
pas mon corps